s'il vous plaît madame Efira pour Canal+
s'il vous plaît alors c'est pas votre
première nuit des Césars
c'est ma première c'est effectivement ma
première qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter de bon pour la suite
posez-moi la question qu'est-ce qu'on
peut tout était bon pour la suite toi de
faire un film avec Mademoiselle Virginie
Efira
j'adore
Jérémy qu'est-ce que tu Jérémy qu'est-ce
que tu viens de dire est-ce que tu
aurais du bain de boule parce que j'ai
mangé des oignons et j'ai pas ce à quoi
j'ai répondu oui on a du bain de bouche
et ce à quoi sarah a répondu il y a des
brosses à dents d'inviter parce que
qu'est-ce qu'elle a acheté regarde qui
est là dans l'escalier parce que l'autre
fois quand même les 12 brosses à dents
ça suffit on a des brosses à dents pour
les inviter regarde-moi ça je crois que
tu vas pouvoir regarde-moi ça tu vas
pouvoir choisir ton voleur
[Musique]
l'artiste qu'est-ce que tu nous prépares
un petit clip
un petit clip un petit clip bien habillé
comme ça
et voilà
alors j'ai les chiffres pour un poste de
Selena Gomez sur les réseaux sociaux
donc sur Instagram une marque doit payer
en moyenne un million
594833 euros et pour une story donc
c'est les vidéos qui restent pendant 24
heures de 15 secondes ça coûtera
[Musique]
797416 euros
je quitte l'émission je me lance
trois hommes une femme trois hommes une
femme mange leur dit c'est bizarre votre
émission il y a des garçons et on me dit
oui en fait on triche déjà on met plus
de femmes qu'on a de candidates parce
qu'en fait les femmes sont très peu
nombreuses à se présenter et donc on m'a
dit ben c'est comme ça c'est une
émission il y a 3e une femme je leur
dise pas possible
aujourd'hui dans une dans une dans un
pays dans une société on essaie de
mettre la parité en avant et
l'équilibrer les droits aux femmes tu
peux pas faire une émission même si
c'est un jeu télé avec trois hommes une
femme